hi there this is Steve Kaufman here
again a different angle in my study you
can see some of my CDs my language CDs
in the background there a few other
little objects that my grandchildren
have left in here I've been asked to do
a video on the subject of you know do we
really need to learn languages how
useful are they we had on my blog the
linguist on language I think it was
freedom and said that as long as we
learn English that's really all we need
he was disappointed in China and how
little he was able to use his Chinese or
how it wasn't very necessary for his job
so what our comment was the request that
I comment on how useful it is to learn
languages for work or for professional
purposes well I'm not quite sure what
I'm gonna say on this subject but let's
begin with my own case I have a business
in lumber which has been successful
enough I would not have been able to
build up that business without my
languages it was my knowledge of
Japanese that enabled me to establish
contacts in Japan that enabled me
sometimes to understand things that
other people didn't understand and so
forth in addition I had very close
relationships with people with whom I
spoke French and I would not have had
those relationships and they were
extremely valuable to me I was able to
develop supply in Sweden I should say
France was a market for us but also I
met people to introduce me to people in
particular in Sweden where we have and
continue to do a lot of business where
we buy lumber and I have had many
occasions to use my Swedish in Sweden
it's not necessary I think it helped as
helped it's hard to measure I have used
my languages I have used my Chinese I
have used Spanish I remember once going
to Spain when we were selling lumber
there and one of our competitors said
that Steve if he speaks Spanish you know
that that's gonna really give him a big
advantage I have found throughout that
people prefer to speak their own
and that if you can speak that language
you have an advantage however you know
do you need it know if you are not a
good businessman if you are a jerk you
know speaking a language is not gonna
hide that they will find that out and so
just the fact that you have a language
doesn't necessarily mean that you don't
have to do all the other things that you
have to do as a businessman but I think
that speaking languages at least in my
own case has been a tremendous asset now
the discussion began on my blog because
I said that it's really a disgrace that
the Foreign Affairs Minister of the
European community can only speak
English now somebody made the cut I
called her Lady Ashton or whatever her
name is someone said no it's not lady is
Baroness who cares I mean it's so
artificial who cares what a Baroness is
a I don't care if a person was born you
know into a family of 15 generations of
Baroness's or whether as in the case of
this person she was a socialist
appointed by another socialist to carry
some heiress to cravaack title who cares
however the point is she only speaks
English now I think that the European
community where people speak a number of
languages she would have an easier job
doing her job she would be able to
create better relationships with people
within the community and outside the
community if she spoke even a couple of
other languages
maybe Spanish maybe French maybe German
maybe Chinese I think this would be an
attribute and I think to have someone
monolingual as the Minister of Foreign
Affairs strikes for a community where
people speak so many languages strikes
me as odd
now she obviously he was selected for
the job whether or not she has all the
other qualities that are required to do
that job effectively I don't know if she
spoke a few languages I think she would
be more successful now let's get back to
this idea of the necessity of learning
any language for that matter English is
certainly the most use
International language no one can argue
that point but even for English today I
was with a person who teaches English
he's a Canadian who teaches English at a
Japanese high school and he's got these
classrooms full of 40 or 50 Japanese
high school kids who know full well or
have been told often how important
English is for their career
most of them apparently aren't the
slightest bit interested in learning
English and will only do the minimum
that's required to pass their test
period so the fact that it's necessary
or not necessary or English is more or
less useful I think for those high
school kids it wouldn't matter what the
language was to them it's a matter of
I've got a test I'm gonna do the minimum
to pass the test be it Spanish chemistry
English it doesn't matter this evening I
went to french-speaking meet up here in
Vancouver where I've been I was there
once a year ago I just curious to see
what people are up to and there's a
gentleman there from Algeria
french-speaking and he said that the
best teacher he had for English was
someone who would close the door because
it was against the regulations at the
school and he would teach them the words
to Yellow Submarine yesterday and and
those kinds of songs and everybody from
that class went on to be the best
English speaker of whatever other
institution they went to thereafter and
they did well not because someone told
them it was important but because the
teacher had found a way to make them
interested in the language and so I
guess I get back to this thing that you
know there's no point if someone says to
me you don't need to learn other line I
speak English the world speaks English
why should I bother learning French
Spanish Chinese Arabic or any other
language I'm not gonna try to persuade
them that the wrong I'm not gonna try to
persuade them that no really in fact you
know you need these other languages if
they ask me whether I have benefited
from speaking these languages
say yes like I did today but I'm not
gonna persuade them and I think it's
hard to tell kids in a classroom
you should learn this language because
it's good for you
that's what they do in Canada in the
schools you should learn French because
it's the national language or something
that doesn't do it for most people
however if you can do the equivalent of
this teacher and find out what they're
interested in
might be the Beatles songs in the case
of English might be I don't know I mean
me in terms of in case of Japanese it
might be something else for Spanish
maybe Spanish pop songs I don't know but
I think that's the biggest challenge for
anyone that's in the business of
language instruction is like that
teacher in Algeria how do you find
something that people are interested in
and if they are interested they'll learn
and so then the issue of whether it's
necessary or important really doesn't
matter and you actually learn better if
you are interested in the subject
not surprisingly so if Lady Ashton or
Barisan Ashton is interested in proving
her French and if she goes to Exxon
follows her somewhere and goes to school
and gets introduced to the conditional
and the subjunctive and which verbs
takeoff Wow
and which verbs take it she will waste
her time
however if Lady Ashton or Baroness
Ashton is interested in certain kind of
music maybe she likes Jacques she'll has
never well now I'm dating myself I guess
there's more recent singers or if she
likes gardening or cooking or history or
whatever she likes if she could be
introduced to interesting content and a
way to to you know learn from that
through the repetitive listening
initially and and and doing the kinds of
things that I always talked about at
this book I mean she has a chance I
should also add that this teacher from
Japan said that they have these 50
Japanese kids in a classroom and they go
through texts and basically it's like a
code-breaking exercise word for word
phrase for phrase the teacher
explain to them what this what these
funny words mean that's about all they
do they don't spend a lot of time
listening to the language they don't do
any reading on their own they're
basically refused to do anything outside
the classroom so I mean that's a
hopeless situation somehow you can't
force it at them you can't try to
browbeat them into telling them that
it's important that some Anglophone says
to me I don't need to learn any
languages because I speak English as a
fine the trick is how do you find
something that might just make them
interested and if you can make them
interested then the sort of utility of
the language is secondary I don't think
the utility of the language is
necessarily the most motivating factor
it's the interest and as you know and
making finding interesting content and
doing things that are not annoying like
most of the exercises and drills that
people have to do decoding texts and so
forth so there you have it my take on
our language is useful other than
English I rather stop now